soir eric coquerel merci de répondre
dotation en direct sur arte france donc
la cour de cassation reporte sa décision
votre réaction pourquoi selon vaut
peut-être pour peut-être que les
derniers éléments révélés notamment par
le journal libération les intéresse
c'est à dire très concrètement le fait
que l'état français savait ce qui était
7e cet agrément qui permettait à lafarge
de continuer à travailler en échange de
15 millions de 13 millions d'euros de
pots-de-vin 15 millions de dollars
ça c'est le fait nouveau de cette
semaine c'est à dire que jusqu'à
maintenant on pensait que l'état
français taux était intervenue après la
prise de ces cuisines de cette
cimenterie par ardèche en septembre 2014
on se souvient notamment des articles
avaient révélé qu' il ya eu une
intervention manifestement du ministère
des affaires étrangères d'alors pour
demander aux américains de ne pas
bombarder ses cuisines qui je rappelle
rapportait beaucoup attaches et donc
financer ses opérations terroristes mais
là c'est deux semaines ce qu'on a appris
c'est tout autre c'est le fait que
l'état français aurait été courant au
courant avant de cette négociation de
lafarge
et là évidemment c'est une affaire
d'état extrêmement grave alors justement
on le rappelle ce qu'a révélé libération
cette semaine des documents de la dgse
donc de la direction générale de la
sécurité extérieure stipule que l'état
français était donc au courant de ces
versements à des ch
et si ces faits sont avérés eric
coquerel quelles suites pénales je pense
notamment au président en exercice à
l'époque françois hollande lé premier
ministre de l'époque jean marc ayrault
manuel valls et puis aussi laurent
fabius qui était au quai d'orsay entre
2012 et 2016
écouter regarder de quoi est accusé
lafarge s'est quand même des accusations
extrêmement graves qui t'ont ce rallye
suite à partir du 7 septembre
le fait d'être complice de crimes contre
l'humanité en syrie et ça ça bout de soi
même et c'est d'ailleurs normal parce
que en finançant des shs aux finances
les opérations terroristes
on finance les réseaux qui ont permis à
des gens non seulement de sévir sur
place dans cette partie du monde mais de
sévir aussi dans des pays comme le nôtre
si jamais enfin les ce qui n'est plus à
prouver c'est la note de la jci 0,7
enfin il est vraisemblable ça serait
étonnant qu'il y a pas de présomption
d'innocence
lafarge le peuple ne fait-il pas le
devait également d'un procès peut-être
médiatique avant d'avoir été jugé
on verra bien mais enfin lafarge vous
l'avez dit vous-même vous n'avez pas
présenté les l'agrément ou de
journalisme va présenter l'agrément de
15 millions de dollars comme quelque
chose au conditionnel on sait bon donc
la question après c'est de savoir
quelles charges vont être retenue parce
qu'à partir du moment où il ya eu
négociation de lafarge pour pouvoir
continuer ses activités cde fait une
négociation avec d une entité terroriste
là dessus il ya pas photo alors après on
verra qu'est-ce-qui dont les charges qui
ont été qui les concernent quelles
charges serait retenu mais moi je
n'hésite pas à parler c2c du djihad au
capitalisme le terme qui mérite lafarge
cette affaire maintenant je vous dis ce
qu'il va falloir remonter c'est de
savoir
j'espère que la justice va s'en saisir
puisque déjà maintenant quelques médias
doivent aux 200 saisissent tous et qui
avait un silence là-dessus terrible
pourquoi sinon cela dit ce qu'il
naissance de la note des loges du sel au
gouvernement effectivement on en parle
libération en parler également mais vous
dit hier un silence radio
comment est-ce que vous expliquer ce
silence médiatique par rapport à tout ça
justement interrogé les chaînes
d'information et les radios concurrentes
la vôtre je sais pas vous leur demandez
pas si quand même énorme
quiconque a découvert cet article de
libération est énorme puisque à l'époque
comme vous l'avez dit les premiers
ministres monsieur ayrault c'est
monsieur val celui qui calomnient tout
le monde en les traitant d'islam au
gauchisme bon si jamais il était au
courant de cette note de la dgca
j'allais dire que ça va alourdir son
dossier avait déjà un dossier lourd avec
les les négociations d'armement avec
l'arabie saoudite il preuve du contraire
est tout sauf une démocratie est tout
sauf favorable à un islamisme modéré
là maintenant si jamais il était au
courant la 10e ça donne de la dgca là ça
doit aller beaucoup plus loin
cette note ça m'étonnerait vue sont vu
son caractère explosif ainsi que les
spectateurs pour peine
c'est une note il relatait l'agrément la
négociation entre lafarge
il est le hockey maurice d'âge en 2014
je le dirai ça m'étonnerait que la note
de la dgse soit resté dans l'ignoble à
des gestes
donc comme vous l'avait dit il ya pas
deux ministres qui peuvent être
concernés manuel valls jean marc ayrault
le prénom la vie qui était à l'époque
ministre libyen falloir qu'on voit clair
parce que c'est assez insupportable si
lafarge venait à être condamné que
risque là les salariés de l'entreprise
les salariés longue date dans
l'entreprise parce que par effet boule
de neige
est-ce qu'il peut pas y avoir des
répercussions financières des pertes
financières dues à la mauvaise image
causés par cette affaire pour
l'entreprise et donc peut-être des
licenciées n'on plus tard il ya
peut-être aussi moyens que l'on change
tous les dirigeants et convenait deux
heures deux heures dans les affaires
bon je ne sais pas en tout cas je suis
désolé mais ça ne peut pas je te
comprends bien la préoccupation par
rapport aux salariés mais ça ne peut pas
que la préoccupation première
pour le premier c'est de savoir si oui
ou non
lafarge seule entreprise apprend l'avoir
fait à négocier avec les terroristes de
dice voilà moi c'est ça qui me semble
important parce que parce que encore une
fois signé à notre président peut y
avoir 200 entreprises également derrière
vous avez dit dans votre j'ai entendu
tout à l'heure dans vôtre vous avez
rappelé justement que les autres
entreprises françaises sont partis il y
en a qu'une qui est resté parce que
parce qu'elle estimait pouvoir continuer
à faire des affaires bon voilà donc le
bilan c'est qu'il ya eu des chalets a
profité à double titre de ces affaires
il en a profité avec les 15 millions de
dollars dont vous parliez tout à l'heure
que vous avez que vous avez évoquées et
il en a prouvé qu'il en a profité aussi
en en pouvant prendre lusine attacked et
en pouvant continuer à la faire tourner
et là je rappelle aussi qu'il ya une
demande ne pas bombarder lusine
manifestement d'après le journal
libération encore aux américains donc je
veux dire ça alimenter sa demande quoi
c'est la mort des arbres
ces aliments possiblement des
logistiques pour faire des attentats
vous voyez quand même qu'on est dans une
affaire extrêmement la merci eric
coquerel d'avoir éperonné une question
je rappelle qu'elle vous êtes député et
les filles de seine-saint-denis